et parlons culture à présent avec
sephora namani qui vient nous parler de
la casim édition du festival du cirque
des mureaux qui vient d'avoir lieu
bonsoir à sephora voussoirs florennes
louis ce week-end pour la quinzième
année le parc du ce au tour des mureaux
à cuillé à nouveau son chapiteau créé en
2002 ce festival est devenu
incontournable et fait désormais partie
des plus grands festivals internationaux
tous les aficionados des numéros de haut
vol ont ainsi pu assister durant deux
jours un véritable tour du monde des
arts du cirque
le concept avec le clown cappuccino
membres de l'organisation du festival ce
spectacle là c'est après tacle éphémère
avant de deux jours avec quatre
représentations les artistes arrivent le
mercredi le mardi ou mercredi pour
oeuvrer le samedi et dimanche donc c'est
un travail de quatre jours intensifs
pour justement mettre en place un
spectacle qui eux qui donnent quelques
par l'illusion d'être un spectacle
abouti depuis des semaines et des
semaines
non faut savoir qu'un festival l'essence
même d'un festival ce sont des
spectacles éphémères
alors pendant ces deux jours quatorze
numéros de voltige dressage et d'
équilibre réalisé par des circassiens
venus du monde entier étaient présentés
par illustre monsieur loyal endossée par
christopher vanesse pour la quatorzième
fois le spectacle était d'accompagnants
live eux par un orchestre et cette année
deux grandes familles traditionnelles
par année ce festival la famille
micheletti maîtresse de cet art depuis
1892 et la famille rech
alors ce festival permet aux jeunes
talents de démarrer aux côtés d'artistes
internationaux comme le suisse dominik
et gras il ya serre et son groupe de
l'yonne ou encore la somptueuse
cavallari orchestrée par l'un des plus
célèbres maître écuyer français sacha
houcke oui tout à fait alors ça c'est
pour la partie dressage domptage et
c'est vrai qu'on a tendance associés
spontanément les animaux au cirque
pourtant le domptage n'est arrivé dans
le monde circassien qu en 1819 à savoir
que depuis les jeux antiques romains et
les troubadours du moyen-âge la première
représentation du cirque traditionnel
date de 1768 à londres depuis 1774 pour
la france et ne comprenait que des
numéros de dressage équestre et
acrobatique et savez-vous d'ailleurs
pourquoi la piste des chapiteaux et
circulaires floral je crois que c'est
pour tenir les chevaux en longe avec une
certaine distance hier exactement et
alors donc le cir qui évolue peu à peu
il soufflé f1 20e on se tourne
aujourd'hui vers un cirque plus théâtre
réalisé à la manière de la compagnie du
cirque du soleil en gardant toujours le
côté spectaculaire des numéros avec un
engagement sportif toujours plus
importants à l'image de celui de xavier
bouvier qui présentait pendant le
festival un numéro d'équilibriste emma
chinois c'est un vrai bonheur pour moi
parce que je fais pas vraiment partie
des familles de cirque
moi je travaille plus dans les cabarets
et plus dans le domaine de
l'événementiel
donc là c'est un nouveau domaine pour
moi ça a permis de partager mon travail
est de voir que ça plaisait aussi au
cirque il y a quand même des artistes
exceptionnels qui sont qu une renommée
internationale
donc d'être parmi eux c'est
un vrai bonheur
et
merci beaucoup sephora vraiment c'est
l'état qui donne vraiment envie d'aller
le voir on vous retrouve mercredi pour
un nouveau numéro de kiosques le
magazine culturel sur saint quentin en
yvelines et nous finissons avec du sport
à présent pour la septième année
consécutive la course cycliste
paris-nice s'est élancé depuis les îles
et la ville de conflans sainte honorine
a accueilli ce dimanche le prologue de
l'épreuve une course remportée par
michael matthews les images sont signés
il une première c'est désormais une
tradition pour la septième année
consécutive la course cycliste paris
nice organisé jusqu'au 13 mars été
lancés depuis les yvelines cette année
la ville de conflans sainte honorine a
été choisi pour le prologue de cette 74e
et